[موسيقى]
اذا الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصوننا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
فاذا حدثت صاحبك واخذته حجتك فحسن مخرج
ذلك عليه ولا تظهر الظفر به السلام عليكم
نقول اسد طبيب المريض يعالجه وداواه
والاسود دواء وجمعه اسيا يقال للطبيب
الاتي ويسمى المريض الاسي يقول ابو الطيب
المتنبي في وصف اسد
يطئ الثرى مترفقا في تيته فكانه اس يجس
عليلا
يعني شفت الطبيب كيف يضع يده على المريض
هكذا
بسهوله بلطف بلين يريد ان
يلتمس موضع الداء هكذا يشبه المتنبي كيف
يدوس الاسد
هنا هو الطبيب والارض هي المريض فهذا
هذا الوطء المترفق هو نفسه الوضع المترفق
ليد الطبيب على المريض
ويقول العرب اسى بينهم اي اصلح فكانه عالج
ما بينهم من خلاف ويقول العرب اقتسى به
بمعنى اقتدى اي جعله اسوه ومنه قوله تعالى
لقد كان لكم في رسول الله اسوه حسنه وقرات
بالوجهين واسي بالكسر حزن ومنه قوله تعالى
لكي لا تاسوا على ما فاتكم ولا تفرحوا بما
اتاكم يقول متمم ابن نويره يقولون تبكي كل
قبر رايته لقبر ثوى بين اللواء والزكادك
فقلت لهم ان الاسى يبعث الاسى دعوني فهذا
كله قبر مالك
[موسيقى]
فاجتاز يوما مع المنصور بدار عاتكه فقال
يا امير المؤمنين هذا بيت عاتكه بنت يزيد
الذي يقول فيه الاحوص يا بيت عاتكه الذي
اتعزل حذر العدى وبه الفؤاد موكل
فاستغرب المنصور وقال ما هاج من الفتى ليس
طبعه كيف يخبر بما لم يستخبر عنه ويجيب
بما لم يسال عنه وابو جعفر يحفظ القصيده
فجعل يردد ابيات القصيده في نفسه الى ان
بلغ الى اخرها وهو بيت قيل في مدح عمر بن
عبد العزيز
واراك تفعل ما تقول وبعضهم مذق اللسان
يقول ما لا يفعل ففهم المنصور تعريض الفتى
واستحسنه فدعا بالوزير وقال له هل دفعت
للمدني ما امرنا له به فقال اخرته عله كذا
يا امير المؤمنين فقال ضعفها له وعجلها
يقول الحصري القيرواني هذا احسن افهام من
الفتى وادق فهم من المنصور ولم اسمع في
التعريض بالطف منه
[موسيقى]
يقال في درجات المطر الطل وهو ما فوق
الندى ودون المطر والوبل المطر الشديد ضخم
القطر والصيب المتدفق شديد الانصباب ومنه
قول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في
الاستسقاء اللهم صيبا نافعا وقول العرب
الطل بشاره الوبل
[موسيقى]
ذكر صاحب العقد الفريد ان ابا يعقوب
الخريمي سمع منصور ابن عمار يقول في دعائه
اللهم اغفر لاعظمنا ذنبا واقسام قلبا
واقربنا بالخطيئه عهدا واشدنا على الدنيا
حرصا فقال له امراه طالق ان كنت دعوت الا
لابليس
[موسيقى]
في منتصف القرن الرابع الهجري كانت هناك
غزوه تسمى غزاه المصيبه امعن فيها سيف
الدوله في النكايه بعدوه الرومي خلال
عودته منتصرا كانت امام الجيش سريه تسبق
الجيش فلما راها خصم سيف الدوله اللدود
قائد جيش الروم اعتبر ان هذا او اعتقد ان
هذا هو الجيش كاملا فهاجم اوائلهم وكان في
الوف من جيشه
فتراجعت هذه السريه حتى ادركت الجيش كاملا
جيش سيف الدوله والتحمت بالجيش ثم استبسل
سيف الدوله في قتال الروم حتى فرق قائد
الجند وقتل كثيرا من فرسانهم واسر من
بطارقتهم
وخلد المتنبي ابداع الفعل بابداع القول
تمشي الكرام على اثار غيرهم وانت تخلق ما
تاتي وتبتدع من كان فوق محل الشمس موضعه
فليس يرفعه شيء ولا يضع وقد المح الى هذه
المفارقه البديعه بقوله بالجيش يمتنع
السادات كلهم والجيش بابن ابي الهيجاء
يمتنع
في سياق تصوير المتنبي لسيف الدوله
باعتباره مفردا بصيغه الجمع وانه هو جيش
الجيش نستحضر قوله في قصيده الحدث الحمراء
اذ يقول يكلف سيف الدوله الجيش همه وقد
عجزت عنه الجيوش الخضارم ويطلب عند الناس
ما عند نفسه وذلك ما لا تدعيه الضراغم
لله ذر المتنبي
[موسيقى]
في الحكمه تقول العرب ثلاثه لا تكون الا
في ثلاثه الغنى في النفس والشرف في
التواضع والكرم في التقوى وقالوا ثلاثه لا
تعرف الا في ثلاثه ذو الباس لا يعرف الا
عند اللقاء وذو الامانه لا يعرف الا عند
الاخذ والعطاء والاخوان لا يعرفون الا عند
الشدائد وقالوا ثلاثه لا بقاء لها ظل
الغمام وصحبه الاشرار والثناء والكاذب
وقالوا عليكم بثلاث جالس الكبراء وخالص
الحكماء وسائل العلماء وقالوا ثلاثه لا
يندم على ما سلف اليهم الله عز وجل فيما
عمل له والمولى الشكور فيما اسدي اليه
والارض الكريمه فيما بذر فيها
[موسيقى]
والاعرابي اذا قيل له يا عربي فرح بذلك
وهش والعربي اذا قيل له يا اعرابي غضب فمن
نزل الباديه اوجها وراء البادين فضعن
بضعنهم وانتوى بانتوائهم فهم اعراب ومن
نزل بلاد الريف واستوطن المدن والقرى
العربيه وغيرها مما ينتمي الى العرب فهم
عرب وان لم يكونوا فصحاء
[موسيقى]
حكى ابن الجوزيه رحمه الله في كتاب
الاذكياء ان الهدهد قال لسليمان عليه
السلام اريد ان تكون في ضيافتي فقال له
سليمان انا وحدي قال بل والعسكر في جزيره
كذا في يوم كذا فمضى سليمان والجند الى
هناك فصعد الهدهد الى الجو فصاد جراده
وخنقها ورمى بها في البحر وقال يا نبي
الله كلوا فمن فاته اللحم نال من المرق
فيقال ان سليمان عليه السلام والجند ضحكوا
من ذلك حولا كاملا
تبدو القصه اسطوريه فعلا غير ان ابن
الجوزي ذكرها حقا وقال انها من
الاسرائيليات
[موسيقى]
تقول العرب رمي فلان بحجره فما قصه المثل
وما معناه
معناه قبل بنظيره وقرينه الذي هو نده في
الصلابه والصعوبه لان احجام الحجاره
وصلابتها تختلف باختلاف الهدف فصغارها
لصغار الاهداف وكبارها لكبارها وفي حديث
صفين ان معاويه لما بعث عمرو بن العاص
حكما مع ابي موسى جاء الاحنف بن قيس الى
علي كرم الله وجهه فقال انك رميت بحجر
الارض فاجعل معه ابن عباس فانه لا يشد
عقده الا حلها فهم علي ان يفعل فابت
اليمانيه الا ان يكون احد الحكمين منهم
ومعنى كلام الاحنف انك رميت بحجر لا نظير
له فهو حجر الارض في انفراده كما يقال
فلان رجل دهره اي لا نظير له في الدهر من
الرجال
[موسيقى]
كان ايمن ابن خريم الاسدي معتذرا لمعاويه
وكان هواه ان يكون الامر لاهل العراق وفي
هذا يقول لو كان للقوم راي يعصمون به من
الضلال رموكم بابن عباس
ابلغ لديك عليا غير عاتبه قول امرئ لا يرى
بالحق من باسي ما الاشعري بمامون ابا حسن
فاعلم هديت وليس العجز كالراسي فاصدم
بصاحبك الادنى زعيمهم ان ابن عمك عباس هو
الاسي
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر هذا السؤال لماذا
نحب ان نكتب
لماذا نحب ان نكتب سؤال فلسفي وجودي
تكثر فيه ربما النظرات الفلسفيه التي
وجدتها واضحه في اجاباتكم التي ساستعرض
بعضها معكم الان هذه مشاركه من جولي تقول
نكتب لان الكتابه تشعرنا بالمتعه
والاكتفاء والرضا والتفريغ نكتب لان
الكتابه تحملنا عندما نحب الى اجمل عالم
نرسمه في مخيلتنا ونتمنى العيش فيه عالم
لا تشوبه ايه شائبه وانما يشبه المدينه
الفاضله التي نحلم بوجودها
وهذه بتول تقول نكتب لاننا في كثير من
الاحيان لا نفهم انفسنا نحاول التعبير عما
يدور بدواخلنا في محاوله لصياغه انفسنا
بين السطور للكشف عن الروح المخباه داخلنا
ورؤيه الجانب الذي لا نلاحظه من ذواتنا
نكتب عن مخاوفنا الدفين ووحشه الطريق
واحلامنا المبتوره عن الرؤى المتضاربه
والرؤيه المشوشه
محمد الجيهاني يقول لنكشف لانفسنا ولغيرنا
اشياء لم نعلمها من قبل ولنعيش نحن
والقراء تجربه مشتركه
ولنجمد الزمن في اجمل لحظاته
خطاب الجبوري يقول لان الكتابه رساله
والكلمه قضيه والقلم امانه والسطور ثغور
والصفحات صفعات والكلمات لكمات والمحابر
منابر
ولله در المتنبي حين قال
واذا سكت فان ابلغ قائلا قلم لك اتخذ
الانامل منبره الله يقول فكم ميتا احيته
كلمه وكم حيا ارداه حرف الكتابه ثوره ونبض
وخلود
جميل يا خطاب
الاء تقول لان هناك الكثير من الاشياء
التي نود قولها لكن لا نستطيع فتكون
الكتاب وسيله مثاليه للتعبير عما يخرج
داخل صدورنا وقلوبنا لانها
تنفس وشعور انك ما زلت على قيد الحياه
روان تقول لان الكتابه بوح من طراز خاص
في ناس تقول يقول فولتير الكتابه رسم
الصوت اعتقد انه قصد ان تترجم صوتك
الداخلي وما يعتري نفسك من عواطف وافكار
على ورقه وكما ان الكاتب الحقيقي لا يقرا
فالقارئ الشغوف مثلي لا يكتب هكذا تقول
وليد يقول لاننا نحاول البقاء
الفناء مخيف
صمود تقول الكتابه افراغ القلب من كدره
السلام ورغد تقول وسيله للتخليه واداه
للتعافي الذاتي
وعبد الله يقول حتى نعرف انفسنا ونتعرف
على
الامنا واخيرا سالم المعمري يقول لنرضى
نكتب لنرضى
اما انا فاقول لو لم تكن الكتابه امرا
عظيما لما اقسم الله تعالى بالقلم حين قال
نون والقلم وما يسطرون وما يسطر والكتاب
[موسيقى]
اجمعوا على ان اصدق كتاب بعد كتاب الله
تعالى هو صحيح البخاري
جمع البخاري صحيحه في 16 سنه ارتحل فيها
بين العراق والحجاز والشام ومصر فكان لا
يقيم بمدينه الا بما يكفي لجمع الاحاديث
النبويه من صدور علمائها
ويضم كتابه سبعه الاف حديث اختارها بعد ان
غربل
600 الف حديث
ولم يودع كتابه الا ما صح عنده واطمئنت
اليه نفسه
واما الذين سمع عنهم البخاري مباشره
فالفا ومجموع الرواه المذكورين في صحيح
البخاري اكثر من سبعه الاف
لقد نهى الرسول الكريم عن كتابه الحديث في
زمنه كراهه ان يختلط بالقران الكريم ولم
ينهى عن نقل كلامه مشافهه وقد جاء الحديث
الصحيح لا تكتبوا عني غير القران ومن كتب
عني غير القران فليمحه
ولم يبدا تدوين الحديث الشريف الا في سنه
مئه للهجره
بعد ذلك بخمسين سنه بدا جمع الاحاديث في
كتب ومنذ بدايه اشتغال الناس بالحديث كان
ثمه طريقتان لتبويبه حسب الموضوعات وحسب
الرواه من الذين جمعوا الحديث حسب رواته
الامام احمد بن حنبل في مسنده المشهور
الذي ضم اكثر من 26 الف حديث فقد افرد
احمد بن حنبل لكل صحابي فصلا يضم الاحاديث
التي رواها وما نبلغ زمن البخاري الا وجمع
الحديث ودرسه من العلوم الشرعيه المهمه
ولد محمد بن اسماعيل البخاري في بخارى عام
واصوله مختلف فيها بين فارسي وعربي ظل حتى
مماته من اعظم الحفاظ الضابطين وقد رويت
عنه حكايه في هذا الشان
تقول الحكايه جاء البخاري الى بغداد وسمع
بمقدمه عده مشايخ من اهل الحديث فرتبوا له
مجلسا وتامروا لاختبار ضبطه فلما استقر
بالبخاري المجلس بادره احدهم واخذ يلقي
عليه حديثا بعد حديث والبخاري يقول بعد كل
حديث لا اعرفه حتى تمت عشره احاديث
باسانيدها ثم تصدى له رجل اخر في المجلس
وصنع كما صنع الاول وتوالى عليه عشره رجال
وروى كل منهم عشره احاديث اختلطت اسانيدها
ومتونها ولم يعرف منها البخاري حديثا
واحدا فلما انس الرجل ان القوم افرغ ما في
جعبتهم اخذ يسرد عليهم احاديثهم واحدا بعد
الاخر
مصححا الحديث متنا واسنادا
حتى اتى على المئه فسلم له القوم بالضبط
والدقه
قيل فيما قيل حديث لا يعرفه محمد بن
اسماعيل البخاري ليس بحديث
عبقريه البخاري هي منهجه العلمي لقد اختار
سبعه الاف حديث من 600 الف
تعرفون ماذا يعني هذا يعني انه كان يقبل
حديثا ويرفض مقابله 90 حديثا
لم يشغل البخاري نفسه الا بالاحاديث
الصحيحه وكان من علماء الجرح والتعديل
وهذا علم الرجال فلا نحكم على راوي بانه
عدل الا اذا اجتمعت فيه خمس خصال ان يكون
مسلما بالغا عاقلا لم يعرف بالفسق ولم
يبتلى بخوارم المروءه هذه الاخيره معناها
ان لا يتصرف المرء تصرفا بعيدا عن وقار
العلماء
وعندما اخرج تلميذ البخاري مسلم بن الحجاج
القشيري صحيحه اصبحت اعلى درجات الصحه ان
يكون الحديث مذكورا في الصحيحين معا او
كما يقال اورده الشيخان واقوى الاحاديث
الصحيحه التي اوردها الشيخان المتواتر
وهو الذي رواه خلق كثيرون عن خلق كثيرين
مرفوعا الى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
واول حديث في صحيح البخاري
انما الاعمال بالنيات وانما لكل امرئ ما
نوى
صدق رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[موسيقى]
قد يبلغ المرء حلما وهو بعد فتى وقد ترى
الشيخ من بعد الهدى نكصا خلق السفينه هل
ينجي سفينتنا ام هل نعود على اثارنا قصصا
يا صاحبي ان اهل السحر قد جمعوا كي يفتنوا
كيف خذ للساحرين عصاه
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]